mes chers amis c'est un plaisir d'être
avec vous aujourd'hui
d'abord laurent je sais je lis mais je
ne réponds jamais vous avez déjà entendu
on dit joseph daul n'existe pas il est
pas sur les plateaux de presse il
communique mal je peux vous dire que la
communication avec laurent et les
permanentes
elle est au minimum une fois par semaine
c'est le premier président le premier
président de notre organisation avec
lequel j'ai autant de contacts et pas
des contacts et quand laurent appel
c'est pas pour donner les ordres c'est
pour discuter des problèmes profonds que
nous vivons actuellement au niveau de
l'europe
laurent très sincèrement ça vient du
fond du coeur continue comme ça continue
à voyager puisque tu as encore le temps
les présidentielles c'est pas pour
demain donc fait toi beaucoup d'amis au
niveau des pays européens
c'est essentiel pour pouvoir exister au
niveau de l'europe
cher françois scellier moi je peux
prendre deux discours c'est pour ça je
ne serai pas trop long puisque on sait
qu'on est limité en temps ça françois
xavier
je peux souscrire à tout ce que tu as
dit si tu l'appliquent au niveau
européen
tu réussiras genre tu a décrit ce qui se
passe au niveau de l'europe
ce que je vis tous les jours je vais
vous dire simplement deux fêtes ce qui
se passe avec trump ce qui se passe en
chine
personne ne parle de l'inde et s'est
profondément là où va pour vont se
passer beaucoup de choses qui vont nous
concerne et au niveau de l'europe ce qui
se passe en afrique où veulent ignorer
pour le moment ce n'est pas inné
uniquement le climat mais comme nous
voyons comment de cette population
croise si nous n'avons pas dans les
prochains temps une politique spécifique
africaine nous allons simplement dans
dix quinze ans la subir
l'autre point moi j'ai vécu sept après
guerre je suis un produit d'après la
guerre
donc je suis un président heureux la
nouvelle génération est arrivée je peux
prendre ma retraite et surtout je vous
dis travailler bien pour que ma retraite
soit assurée mais quand vous regardez
les pères et les mères de l'europe comme
je cite souvent ce qu'ils ont fait
pendant soixante dix années ce sont des
ppe qui ont construit l'union européenne
n'a pas attendu les autres c'est 70
années de paix et de prospérité vous
allez dire ça c'est pour les vieux
c'est vrai c'est pour nous et maintenant
nous devons adapter pour que l'europe
existe pour que l'europe garde sa place
au sein du monde ça c'est maintenant la
nouvelle génération qui doit le mettre
en place et je compte sur vous pour que
vous travaillez sur ce projet est encore
souvent soir ce projet ne peut pas être
travaillé tout seul par la france
c'est un projet qui doit être partagé en
commun avec l'ensemble des pays tout
seul on n'est rien et là je voudrais
répondre à notre président de la
république monsieur macron je le suis de
très près le nouveau bond je peux lui
dire qu'il va actuellement en marche
arrière
je suis très inquiet du saint laurent
nous avons une position difficile à
défendre mercredi prochain avec notre
année du tome nous devons respecter nos
valeurs nous devons respecter l'état de
droit et mes chers amis en france l'état
de droit n'existe plus dans nos
banlieues
nous avons aussi le devoir de faire
respecter l'état de droit dans nos
banlieues
c'est pour ça avec laurent cette semaine
on s'est téléphoné plusieurs fois je
connais la position des uns des unes et
des autres par rapport au dossier de la
hongrie nommons le comme ça je connais
ce qui se passe avec nos amis allemands
cd ou de ses sous et je suis en train
une fois de plus de préparer un
compromis et j'espère j'espère que nous
arrivons à la fin donc prochain d'un
mercredi prochain que le compromis que
je mettrais sur la table sera adopté par
tout le monde c'est ça aussi
chers amis la responsabilité que nous
avons c'est de trouver des compromis
ensemble pour faire avancer l'europe
merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté vive la
france et vive le rond
toulouse